got a bone to pick with you you killed
Admiral Ackbar in the first 30 minutes I
don't know I know Justice for Akbar
[Music]
Star Wars The Last Jedi
[Music]
hi I'm holding for General hugs this is
hux you and your friends are doomed we
will wipe your filth from the Galaxy
okay I'll hold
hello
yep I'm still here for me everything in
the movie is Star Wars and everything in
the movie I can trace back to deeply in
a deep way with Star Wars is for me and
I know there are I mean everyone has a
different take I know there are Star
Wars fans who somehow have think that
Star Wars was a serious thing like the
Batman movies or something I was so
young that when I watched uh um Empire
Strikes Back it had this deep profound
impact on me because it was terrifying
because I was just young enough to not
experience it as watching a Star Wars
movie but to have it feel like too real
Return of the Jedi was the one that was
exactly the right age to see in the
theater and anyone who
thinks that slightly goofy humor is out
of out of is it does not have a place in
the Star Wars Universe I don't know if
they've seen returns
there's literally a scene where Ann solo
is you know like a cartoon like trust up
to a pole and a torch goes by him to
light the fire to cook him and Han Solo
does this this
even even the first movie they're in the
heart of the Death Star and they're
trying to do this desperate Gambit to
get out with their lives and save the
princess where they're pretending that
Chewbacca is like their prisoner hitting
a little Imperial drug comes up
Chewbacca Roars at it and the Droid like
a scared doggos
slightly self-aware
element of gleeful humor is something
that is part and parcel to Star Wars
it's not the whole thing and we get very
serious in the movie as well and I think
that kind of brazen balance of those two
things is also something that's part of
Star Wars so for me that scene with hux
and Poe uh besides just being a hell of
a lot of fun was also something that
felt essentially Star Wars to me Ash
um what you have learned
strength mastery
that weakness Folly failure also yes
failure most of all the greatest teacher
failure is
I definitely didn't approach the entire
thing as a meta exercise because I think
first and foremost it has to be an
honest expression of what the characters
are actually going through and it's not
very interesting to just think in them
other way about Star Wars at the same
time you're dealing with a story that's
about
um Heroes and about a younger generation
meeting their Heroes and a generation
that is now the older generation of
Heroes dealing with being role models
for the younger generation and still
being human beings with faults and
foibles and somebody who has the role of
a legend you know but who feels fallible
as a human being by the end of the movie
realizing the value that that Legend has
and realizing their play places to step
up and be that for the younger
generation when you're dealing with all
of these things the the legends that we
grew out that I grew up with was the
characters in Star Wars if I think about
the thing in my life that's been the
most consistent thing of that it is
these movies and again they want to make
a Star Wars movie today is is in some
way going to be engaging with their
relationship with Star Wars itself
Knives Out
[Music]
detective blank
you said the investigation is ongoing
you made a point of that do you expect
Foul Play Mr Blanc
if you please
there is much that remains unclear but
yes
I suspect Foul Play I was coming off and
making the Last Jedi which had been the
best experience in my life but it was it
was four years it was four years of my
life basically making that one film it's
not um ever helpful to try and get too
strategic in terms of thinking of what
you do next I kind of have to just go
with whatever
seems the most exciting in that moment
for whatever reason it was this murder
mystery it was this little whodunit that
I had kind of been cooking in the back
of my head for about 10 years I turned
it out relatively quickly for me it was
it was about a six month writing process
I think previously could get very
precious about scripts and spend years
chewing on them and I think I think you
can overcook something there was
something very liberating about just
saying okay I'm going to write this
thing relatively quickly I didn't know
what to expect when I came into doing
the first one you know I'd worked with
some famous movie stars I'd worked with
like well-known actors I'd never worked
with this big an ensemble where
everybody in it is so much their own
name I'm not very confrontational and
I'm like I was very nervous about what
that was going to be like on set it
ended up being fantastic everybody
showed up ready to be part of an
ensemble and there was no ego there was
no none of that everybody was supporting
each other I think maybe just the very
nature of it we got people coming in who
were excited to kind of snap back into
that Drama Camp type Vibe of just uh
it's not about me or you it's about us
and it's about this whole group sort of
working together
I spoke in the car about the hole at the
center of this donut
and what you and Holland did that
fateful night seems at first glance to
fill that hole perfectly a donut hole in
a Donut's hole
but we must look a little closer
and when we do we see the donut hole
has a hole in its Center I think there
is like a perception that with knives
out it was like a deconstruction of the
whodunit or the genre or something
um for me it's it's very much not the
case because I'm such a huge Agatha
Christie fan that's where all of this
comes from is my love of her books and
if you go back and actually look at what
Agatha Christie was doing from the very
very start if you want college
deconstructing she was deconstructing
from the very beginning she was taking
the genre apart even the meta aspect of
kind of characters being aware they're
in the detective story that was there
from the very very start all the
characters in Agatha Christie and even
even in Sherlock Holmes books even
Arthur Conan Doyle's work which vastly
predates that people are aware of the
the tropes of of Thriller stories and
detectives and are calling them out so
for me when you take the whodunit and
you flip it on its head you do something
narratively completely unexpected you do
something that's self-aware about the
genre you're not subverting what
Christie was doing you're in imitating
it oh Jesus I'm gonna disappear until
the politics talk is done you want some
champers
can't I'm technically working
off you Red Cap Richard and look around
you the streets are literally flooded
with Nazi no no no no no no no we are
losing our way of life and our culture
there are millions of Mexicans coming
and don't don't make this a race thing
you always make this a race thing I
would say the same thing if they were
European growing up loving these movies
and TV shows and nearly all of them
being period pieces
um set in England usually and usually
set in some kind of hazy uh nostalgic
version of England that probably never
actually existed so I'll sound like a
broken record but that's not what
Christy was doing back in the day she
was writing to her time into her place
so the notion of doing a traditional
whodunit
um but setting it unapologetically in
America right here and right now and
throwing out any notion of being
Timeless and just saying no we're going
to talk about exactly what everyone's
talking about right now not that I feel
like very motivated to get like to talk
about political ideology in these movies
but I feel like for all of us the
political has become personal it knives
out it's
it's about politics it's really about a
family arguing about politics and it's
about what politics does to your
Thanksgiving dinners what happens when
um when somebody that you grew up loving
suddenly is supporting something
politically that you find abhorrent and
it's about the personal side of that and
that's something that I felt strongly
and felt like I could actually dig into
Glass Onion
from the very start with when even back
when I was making knives out I thought
oh this does well this is something
that'd be fun to keep doing but but
always in the context of
um again the way that Christy did it
wasn't interesting to me the idea of
continuing the last movie or or bringing
back the characters or something it to
me the whole the thing that's fun is Ben
marblock is the same detective but it's
a whole new case whole new cast whole
new deal it's a very interesting thing
though because as as a writer you always
have to keep yourself aware that the
detective is not the protagonist of the
movie he is at the center of it and in
this case we have one of the best actors
and biggest movie stars on the planet
playing our main detective so there's a
gravity of a thousand sons in terms of
Charisma with with
um Daniel on screen has been one block
but his task in it is to be outside this
realm of human drama that you're
creating with the mystery and to be
almost this Godlike figure who floats
above it all and who guides it and
solves it and the reality is if you want
to actually engage an audience if you
want them leaning forward engage what's
going to happen next as opposed to
leaning back stroking their chin trying
to solve it you can't Center the drama
around the detective's Dilemma it has to
be somebody in the group of suspects
that you're worried about like it's fun
to get little glimpses of Benoit blanc's
life it's fun to get a little glimpse of
his home life in this movie but the idea
of building out the mythology of him of
exploring his backstory of finding out
where he came from completely
uninteresting I think it's a mystery
movie it's about out the mystery I
cannot overstate my gratitude to be here
when's the murder mystery start at the
center of this movie of Glass Onion is
uh miles Braun who's played by Edward
Norton and he's a tech billionaire I
mean first of all tonally that kind of
took the movie made the movie a little
broader by its very nature I think why I
had my first conversation with Edward
Norden before he read the script I
warned him we go a little more Strange
Love with this one this is a whole
little a little bigger but that's
entirely because of who it's about and
what it's about It's tricky because you
know obviously there are real life
counterparts that you could you could
point to in terms of the tech
billionaires that we've seen quite a lot
of I found it specifically unhelpful and
uninteresting to think about anyone too
specifically why I was writing and the
instant it became just taking the piss
out of one specific person it got very
boring very quickly what was more
interesting to me is to kind of zoom out
and look at
the odd place that these people have in
the American Consciousness the way that
all of us
have this dual thing and I have it too
where you want to make fun of these
people and throw poop at them there's
also the very American thing in all of
us of kind of mistaking wealth for
competence and wanting them at the same
time to be like Willy Wonka maybe they
can solve it all maybe we can maybe they
maybe they do have the answers that kind
of tension and uh and the way that we're
all dealing with sort of the revelation
of of uh um maybe it's not the best idea
to trust these people that was a lot
more interesting to me than the idea of
honing in on one specific person
Looper
I had had like a two-page script for
this short for um for Looper and there
was just kind of like a Logitech style
like voice over driven little sci-fi
shorts and they've been sitting in a
drawer and never made up the idea seemed
really intriguing to me and coming out
of the Brothers Bloom this big personal
movie that kind of that kind of flopped
at the box office I thought ah God this
is it have I have I blown it do I get to
do I not get to keep making movies so
sitting down to right Looper I took this
idea and I really I rewrote that movie
more than I've ever Rewritten anything
in my life I really tried to hone it
down and make something that was tight
and something that was going to
conceptually work I was thinking about
um you know Cameron's first Terminator
movie as as kind of the example of
something I want to do or witness Peter
Weir's witness something that has kind
of the the focused shape of a very
determined thought out structure and
then just sees it through to its
inevitable conclusion and almost like a
compassionately cruel type way the real
origin of it for me was the idea of I
mean there's a lot of stuff in there
about Fathers and Sons there's a lot of
stuff in there about the idea of
violence the idea of Retribution the
idea of its actual utility as a
problem-solving tool
foreign
foreign
take this truck you take your gold and
go live your life nobody's coming after
you
I fixed it do you go kill the boy that's
how you fix it you're goddamn right I'm
gonna kill that boy
you just got your life back my life
good life
becoming you I wanted Joe to look more
like Bruce I thought it would be fun
like we're making a sci-fi movie let's
go for it you know let's take the extra
step and also Joe is an actor who in my
experience he's he's kind of an old
school like Lawrence Olivier style actor
where he kind of works from the outside
to find the inside he finds the voice he
finds the posture he finds the costume
and that helps him find his way to the
inner core of who the character is so
the notion of starting with literally a
new face where in the morning he would
get a makeup and look in the mirror and
be looking at someone completely
different was really appealing to him
and felt like the kind of fun swing that
we could try with this and we also got
one of the best makeup artists in the
world Kazu hero to do the makeup for it
and um because he's a true artist so
getting a chance to collaborate with
Kazu on that was another big motivation
Breaking Bad
Vince Gilligan had a gun in touch after
he saw brick we tried to do something in
the second season and I wasn't available
because I was off making the brothers
balloon luckily he came back to me for
season three and I got to do this
episode The Fly which was a bottle
episode which means you know they've
kind of run out of money for the rest of
the season and they need an episode
where they can shoot in one set with a
couple of characters
[Music]
ah he's not coming down
must be Thailand hot up there
that's why he likes it
Island's hot right
yeah what that meant for me was I got a
very concentrated dose of working with
these two amazing actors with Bryan
Cranston and Aaron Paul the writers
Moyer Wally Beckett and Sam Catlin both
of whom I got to work with on future
episodes had written this incredible
scripts and I got to come in and and
think about how do I make this cinematic
I got to think about how do I take this
one space and have us not get visually
bored with it just stop for one second
look I told you to get your things
there is no time tell me about Uncle hey
what's wrong with you you have to tell
me Dad wait what happened to uncle Hank
get out I'm still kind of Blown Away
that I got to direct Ozymandias and it's
entirely just because of my relationship
with the writer more uh Wally Beckett
who I did the fly with and we had stayed
in touch and she brought me in on that
and really trusted me with that amazing
script that she wrote um and we really
collaborated we were really a team on it
it's very intense episodes for all of
the characters usually in any given
episode there's like one scene that okay
this is going to put everyone through
the ringer and then Ozymandias every
single scene was like that I mean I came
away with it just with so much respect
for Anna Gunn as a actor she's
extraordinary and there's a scene where
Anna has to has to break down and it was
also a very physically difficult scene
because it was it was cold it was
outside in the street she has to run out
and like fall down to her knees and
really you're just facilitating and the
reality is it's not like you're getting
them there or like guiding them or
showing them what to do or whatever your
job as a director is to give the actors
whatever they need to go to the places
that they need to go and whatever that
means if the for it means different
things for different actors they're on
their journey and they're wherever Anna
took that character in that scene that's
entirely Anna's work new job as a
director is just to make sure that they
feel like they can do that and be safe
brick
[Music]
I was just about to turn 30 when I made
it and most of the actors in it were in
their early 20s
and we were all really young and it was
such an intense bonding experience such
a crucible and I think especially as you
get older you and you keep being having
been lucky enough to keep making movies
you keep doing more and more of them and
you can have these amazing experiences
with people on set and sometimes you
keep in touch with them after but you're
all adults and you kind of go you kind
of come together for the project you go
your separate ways maybe you kind of
stay friends but brick was different the
friendships that I made and the
experiences that I had with people that
I'm still friends with to there the big
thing I can break toad here says Emily
cross which is dead
[Music]
he says he knows who did it
[Music]
says he knows where the body is I wrote
brick when I was right out of college
all right when I was like 22 and
basically spent my 20s failing to get it
made so it being sort of the Specter
that was overall in my 20s just how do I
get brick made how do I get brick made
that defines like that span of my life
and also that when I was 22 in writing
it high school was something I had
relatively it was still a recent
experience and brick being sort of a an
expression of the emotional reality of
what high school felt like it almost
being like a therapy session of
tapping into sort of the dark almost
like mythological emotional landscape of
what that very intense period of life
felt like for me and then going back to
my high school to film it
um it felt like definitely like
exercising some some demons so that was
another intense element of it
you come and I pulled the two-bit toker
because I know what his will would do to
you I love you too much to see you don't
love me
you're the only thing I love
you're the only thing I love
this is how I do it
I want to keep you safe
after spending a decade of your life
trying to get it made and then finally
um finally getting it made and it ended
working that was that felt very
gratifying the other thing was my family
who's in the Home Building business you
know so we made brick for a very small
budget and we made it just by getting
private you know investment from people
that we knew and so I mean my
grandfather put money into the movie and
the fact that I could then go to
Sundance and turn around and see my
family sitting behind me and then be
able to pay my grandfather back I felt
it felt very very very very good
the Brothers Bloom
I guess I didn't know what I didn't know
when I started working making the
Brothers Bloom because I I you know I
grown up just making shorts and not
working with actors at all brick was my
first experience working with actors and
um and then with brick we were moving so
fast and it was a very experienced cast
but it was a very young cast and so they
were all just kind of game I kind of
would just you know I would set up the
camera and tell them where to stand
basically I did I didn't really figure
out how to work with actors in terms of
doing blocking rehearsals or and so I
got to Brothers Bloom I just started
doing it that way but you know I was
working with Rachel Vice and Adrian
Brody and they were also incredibly
patient and lovely I very quickly
learned to work with actors as a whole
other level of collaborating and working
with actors that you got to engage with
and that became one of the real joys of
it I mean the brothers balloon was I
mean that was such an intense experience
for me making that movie I mentioned
before I spent like my 20s broke in La
trying to make brick I didn't have money
to travel I didn't go anywhere and so
the Brothers Bloom kind of wrote it to
manifest like having an adventure
[Music]
I also tried to like stuff everything
that I love into into that movie all at
once my love of Ricky J and con man
movies and traveling and the romance of
all of that going off with this crazy
like traveling circus across Eastern
Europe it was an incredibly intense
um experience and and a really really
beautiful one I'm very proud of the film
and nobody saw it so it was it's kind of
like kathunk which was really
devastating for me I don't know the
feeling of having mustered the troops
and led them into battle and then kind
of uh yeah you feel like you let
everybody down it is really really nice
when somebody comes up to me and tells
me that the movie connected with them
because I feel like because it's kind of
a hidden thing it means even more to the
people who it does connect with and um
and both as a life experience and also
just as a film I'm so I'm just really
proud of it so
Adrienne Newhouse skateboard and so I
think he gave he gave Rachel some tips
he was very uh because you know because
Adrian's a musician and he loves he
loves rap and so the scene where she was
DJing I think he was yeah he was not so
into that
[Music]
that hobby Montage was very fun that's
also kind of I mean for me that's what I
did kind of in my in my 20s I would
collect Hobbies I would just kind of try
a new thing as a way of trying to
because I felt very much trapped at home
I felt very much trapped in my La
apartment and so I would I would get a
cheap banjo and learn how to play the
banjo I got into pinhole photography at
some point I would just kind of try and
open up my universe by looking at things
that I could do you know in uh in my own
little space